(downbeat music)
- I want to remind everybody
of the importance of
giving us little questions.
We have a few, and I think I
first am to summarize briefly
or at least to wrap up,
we covered scales in space and time,
you saw a great number of
technology developments
for imaging, constructing.
There are questions you should be asking
about how do you put it all together,
and a lot of questions about how
does a lot of the technology
that you saw developed
make it beyond these laboratories
where the pioneering is going on,
to a greater number of sites.
You saw a little bit of that,
so that the community can use
these things, extensively.
I think that's enough,
Jennifer can now take the
questions that we've heard
and get the speakers one
by one to answer questions.
Jennifer.
So the way we're gonna do this is,
I'm gonna be sort of asking questions
that I've gotten from people
related to the first
part of the symposium,
and Mark will query the second group.
So actually let's start
with Daniel Colon-Ramos,
if you could come up here,
there's a couple questions for you.
So the first question is,
how does architecture and development
of the C. elegans brain emerge?
Are there fundamental principles
that you've been able to see?
- Right, so, for the most
part it's still a mystery,
we don't know all the
organizing principles.
We do know some that we have
uncovered over the years.
A surprising result that we had early on
was the discovery that, usually
when you form a synapse,
the synapse is formed
by a presynaptic cell
contacting a postsynaptic cell,
and that's in every textbook
and in every cartoon
diagram you can imagine.
And we discovered that
there's a third cell,
which is a glia cell, that
is acting as a matchmaker.
So the presynaptic cell is not talking
to the postsynaptic
cell until the very end.
Instead, the glia cell
talks to a presynaptic cell
and tells it to form synapses.
It also, at the same time,
talks to the postsynaptic cell
and tells it to come to where
the presynaptic cell is,
and then it matches them.
So that's an organizing principle
that we think is gonna be conserved,
actually has been shown to be conserved,
and might be important.
- And one other question relates to,
how could you get better imaging?
What are the limitation,
could you image all movements of the worm?
- Right, so, I'll answer
that question by saying,
in today's talk including Jennifer's talk
and the talks we just saw,
there are different levels of imaging.
You can image activity,
you can image the tissue,
you can image single cells,
you can image subcellularly.
And I think that that
level of understanding
is gonna be necessary.
We are limited by the number of colors
that we have available,
which I love your talk,
talking about the spectral imaging,
I'm gonna go back and look into that.
We are also limited by the temporal scale,
I mean we can image for
prolonged periods of time,
which is very enabling, right now,
but being able also to image
for prolonged periods of times
at even higher resolution
and multiple things at the
same time will be fantastic.
- And that is, come on over,
what are the cyclical shape
changes in the dendritic spines,
that you had mentioned?
And what is the purpose of these changes?
What are the correlated with?
- So, there are a number of
changes that have been described
that are associated with
development of spines.
So as I showed you, one
shot of the fragile X mouse,
where there's a specific protein
associated with chaperoning
messenger RNA that is mutated,
and the spines seem to keep
trying to find a partner,
and never mature into what's
the typical mushroom shape.
So part of the variation
that you saw in those images
has to do with whether or
not you're in the process
of partnering up, and you
complete the partnering up.
Then there are activities
related to spine enlargement
that have been described,
associated with long-term potentiation,
which are well documented.
Some people believe,
and there's some evidence
in the literature,
that there are actomyosin interactions
closer to the top of the neck,
before you get into the
bulb part of the spine.
So the spine has some actin modulation.
Then, there are studies
just recently published,
we participated in these
in February, in Science,
showing that if, and this
is from Chiara Cirelli,
and Tononi, I think I got the name right,
showing that dendritic
spines, the majority of them,
shrink by 20% if you've been
sleeping about three hours,
or at least if a mouse has been sleeping
at the time that you harvest the tissue.
So, predict, and I guess
I'm allowed to do that,
that spines go through a cycle, day night.
And that when you're learning something
and your postsynaptic
process has been facilitated,
it holds that state for a while.
But then somehow you have to transfer
whatever that information is
that's been encoded in the
dendrite to stabilize that neuron
in a way that that information is stored
in that region of the brain.
So that so-called
downscaling of the response,
the LTP response, has to
be translated, perhaps,
into differences in the
connectivity between those neurons.
Probably their inhibition, by
activating synapse formation
by the inhibitory interneurons.
So that's the kind of state
of thinking at this point.
- The question for Na is,
do you see calcium being released
from astrocytes in addition to neurons?
If so, how are they different?
- That's a great question.
The technology we have
can definitely be applied to astrocyces
but we haven't tried that yet.
But there is a big community of people
who are doing calcium
imaging in astrocytes.
So I would imagine there
must be some difference.
I think in general the time
transient is much smaller,
and it doesn't have this stereotypical
kind of impulse function shape.
And actually the Brain Initiative
has a new call for proposals
where they would like
people to develop probes
as well as data analysis
methods for astrocytes,
because they are behaving
quite differently from neurons.
But I don't have personal
experience with it.
- Okay, next is Erik Jorgensen.
Can you speculate on what
controls ultra-fast endocytosis?
At the different temperatures.
Is it ATP, or enzymes, what do you think
is causing that switch in
the mode of endocytosis?
- Right, so we think that
the most likely change
is in the lipid, the nature of the lipid.
So as you cool lipids,
they will eventually go
into a gel-like state,
which will disallow the
sort of shape changes
that we think are going on.
In particular PIP2 shows some
very bizarre interactions
between moving between room
temperature and 37 degrees,
so the fluidity increases.
And so that has something
to do with the head group.
The second thing we think that is going on
is that the fatty acid tails
that are anchored in the membrane
also are having a strong effect,
and so particularly for, so
nematodes live at 20 degrees,
that's not a problem.
But if you raise an animal at 25 degrees
and you drop it to 20 degrees
it can't move anymore.
If you raise an animal at
15 degrees, it moves fine.
And so what we are finding is
that fatty acid desaturases
are what allows these animals
to move better at 15 degrees.
So in the end we think it's going to be
the head groups of the lipids
and the fatty acid tails.
- Don't go anywhere,
because you got a couple more questions.
Have you attempted electrical
stimulation of the synapse
that mimics actual action
potentials in the axon?
If accurate, exocytosis would not occur
with every stimulation,
the number of fused
vesicles might be different
under these circumstances.
- Yeah so, what we'd
love to do is to drive
to clamp the cell with a real
honest to God action potential.
We've of course not been able to do that,
this is just simply an
electrical field stimulation.
And it's absolutely possible
that the shape of the action
potential will have an effect.
Certainly the temperature
of an action potential
will cause it to widen,
and also causes calcium
channels to open slowly.
So, these are things that we know happen,
and we're not able to
do that in our system,
we really need to be able to
voltage clamp those cells,
and then you can only do
that in the calyx of Held,
or some other of these cells
that have large presynaptic terminals.
- One last question. (laughs)
If you calculate the depletion of vesicles
and the renewal rate,
is the 30-second endocytosis
number that you came up with
at the low temperature significant?
- I think the question is,
can you actually replenish vesicles
using clathrin mediated endocytosis
given that there's 200 synaptic vesicles
at a hippocampal synapse.
And the answer is no,
but we don't really know,
and it may be worse than that
because we're not convinced that all
of the vesicles we see by EM
are actually synaptic vesicles
but rather may be storage depot,
the reserve pools maybe, not actually,
even though they look
like synaptic vesicles,
may not be synaptic vesicles.
- Okay, I'm gonna turn
it over to Mark now,
who's got questions for the
second group of speakers.
- Jennifer, does organelle interaction
estimated by light microscopy
match with EM studies?
What's the resolution
obtained by light microscopy?
- That's a really great question.
Basically, when we created
the organelle interactome,
we counted as a contact,
when two organelles share the same pixel,
which was 160 nanometers.
And that's fairly big, so
there could be some overlap
that was not relevant,
but I should emphasize
that the tethering proteins
that are known to tether
two organelles together,
like the VAP protein that I showed,
extend about 100 nanometers or more
off from the surface of
the organelle of interest.
But really to that point,
one of the projects in our lab
is, we've created fret probes
to look at fret interactions,
which take you down into
the nanometric level
that would be approximating
electron microscopy resolution,
to map out frequency of interactions
between different sets of organelles.
But we're just doing that two by two.
We've yet to calculate
the extent of interaction
from the electron micrograph images,
just because of the time that is required
to segment all of those organelles,
and to do that in a whole cell
is still quite challenging.
- So one more while Jennifer's here.
What machine learning framework is used
to train and evaluate
an imaging segmentation
in order to build the 3D model?
- Well we didn't use any
machine learning system at this point,
because some of these
organelles, like the ER,
although we tried to work
with different people
to see whether there'd be a way
that we could train a computational system
to learn how to call an
ER in a particular slice,
it just didn't work.
So we did everything
by hand at this point.
And this is a big area that
I think needs further work
from the machine learning crowd.
- So this is a related question,
not directed to anybody.
So, are machine learning and
deep learning used already
to analyze the brain, map
imaging functionality,
with what research labs, Kavli, et cetera,
plan to collaborate to apply
deep learning algorithms.
So does anybody want to address that?
I can make some comments,
and Harold can probably.
I can start it with, at least my group
has worked extensively
with different groups,
Tolga Tasdizen in Utah, to do
deep learning for organelles,
successfully at this point.
Many of these approaches,
when they're first cooked,
require considerable knowledge,
so you have to make a template,
you have to do the work first by hand
in order to have a training data set
in order to let computational processes
and algorithms that are being
cooked up quite effectively
to find at least a solution
that's as good as yours.
And that's the way the
judgments are being done.
So, most of the labs that are doing this
still are employing
teams of undergraduates,
supervised by the most effective
graduate student or postdoc,
who manages people kinda like
a McDonald's crew or whatever,
to actually get the ground truth.
Then it involves, usually,
using big computers.
Expensive, cycle supercomputers.
So all the ER in a single Purkinje cell,
done that way, initially
for us, which I didn't show,
was a million CPU hours,
between the training the algorithm
and then executing on it.
That, with computer graphics cards, GPUs,
once the software that
you've decided works,
is shown to work properly, is ported,
and then it can be made available
on a small group of machines
that might cost a laboratory
10, $15,000 to put together.
So I think that's the
direction that it goes.
But right now, for example,
Jenalia is relying on Google
to do them a big favor.
Okay, so, that's the
machine learning question.
Now, this one is for Philipp.
Do you think you could
add 4Pi capabilities
to your four-sided light sheet system?
First you have to explain
to them what that means.
- Sure, so, the short answer
is yes you can do that,
but it wouldn't make any
sense for our experiments.
And it's not an obvious
thing, so let me explain.
I mean basically, the 4Pi approach
just means that you have
two opposing objectives
aimed at the sample, and so,
actually one of the slides I showed today
relates to the interest you
might have in that arrangement,
which is that usually you
don't collect all of the light
with a conventional objective
with a limited collection angle,
a limited numerical aperture.
So ideally you want the aperture
to be as big as possible,
and ideally you want to
completely envelope your sample.
With your detection system
you can really grab all of the photons
you can get out of the specimen.
Which relates to signal
collection efficiency,
but also directly to spatial resolution.
And so with the 4Pi approach,
you just have the 4Pi spatial angle,
you have full access to the sample,
and you can combine it
with other principles,
such as standing structured
patterned illumination,
where you can go to
sub-wavelength resolution
by just having counter-propagating waves
set from multiple objectives
that are facing each other.
So there's a lot of potential
in having these more complex arrangements,
but all of them rely on the concept
of very precise wavefront control.
So you're assuming that you will get,
for example you do the
structured illumination approach,
that you can get very
precise interference pattern
inside the sample, so that
you're making an assumption
about what happens to the
light inside the sample.
And so all of the
specimens we're looking at,
the drosophila larvae, the
zebrafish, the zebrafish brains,
zebrafish brain might
be probably the closest
to making this possible, but even there,
we are really perturbing the beams,
we are perturbing the wavefront.
And the errors that we
accumulate in the wavefront
are a much larger order of magnitude
than what level of precise
spatial control you would need
in order to get the resolution
enhancing effects to work.
And so for the most part
we just don't really have
enough penetration and control
to use these approaches.
So in the future you could
potentially improve this
with adaptive optics techniques.
So you can sort of bend
the light back into shape
to some extent by mapping this out.
But then there's still the
problem of light scattering
and so on that is much harder to resolve,
so I think it's an interesting
direction for the future
but right now sort of like
not the most obvious thing
that we would want to push forward.
- Have you looked at axons in the vicinity
of different types of plaques
in the Alzheimer brains?
- Okay, well, I'm not the
person in Alzheimer disease,
so we didn't go into,
very much, the plaques,
so there's controversy whether or not,
which, axon or dendrites
have more neuritis.
I like that debate.
So, yes, actually I have to confess,
we tried to look at the axon,
so the involvement of the
axon in the plaque formation,
but we didn't do that very much yet.
But I'm glad somebody asked me.
(audience laughing)
We hope to do it.
- I asked. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- So, we tried to distinguish
the axon and the dendrites
by some ways, and we didn't
get any good, the antibodies,
but we need that, you can do it.
- So, to turn this into
a brief discussion,
so part of the problem is that the axons
that go to the vicinity
of the neuritic plaques,
this is from analyzing biopsy samples
that we did 35 years ago,
is that of course the
microtubules have depolymerized,
and tau is now stuck in the soma,
so the markers that you'd normally use
to say that's an axon are not there,
but if you look ultrastructurally,
the plaque area is toxic to the axons.
And then you have retrograde degeneration.
So, if there were another marker,
rather than the traditional markers,
or if you could do it with an animal
that had some sort of labeled
lipids of the membrane,
you might see it in a more effective way
than the small samples that we did in the,
I would call it the dark ages.
- So maybe I add one more thing.
So we are now more interested
in the diffused plaques
than the cored plaques.
So the cored plaques have
very nice, clear boundaries,
so maybe proximity can
be analyzed in depth.
But diffuse plaques have
very ambiguous boundaries,
it's more of a challenge
concerning the interaction
with other objects.
So, yep, cored plaques
are maybe a good target.
- Yeah, longer discussion,
maybe, with Dai I or something.
So this, I think this
is the last question,
and it's for Alipasha.
I love this question, I didn't ask it.
Please comment on the
relationship of your finding
to the field of mathematical
modeling of neuronal dynamics.
Good luck.
(audience laughing)
- Well, I think, I don't know exactly
how to answer this question
because it is quite broad,
so what I can say is that,
we hope that our methods provide at least,
within some constraints, the information
that can be then used for
various modeling approaches.
So one thing I can say is that,
one thing that we are trying to do,
is relate it to cortical computation.
So there is an ongoing project
that is aimed at recording
the entire cortical column,
map it, map the dynamic onto
the structural information
that we can get via electron microscopy,
to confine a model, and then try to build
generative computational models
that would be describing the dynamic,
and thereby work towards the algorithms
that are for instance underlying
as that animal has been engaged
in an object recognition task,
and trying to see whether
we can work backwards.
But, this is all I can say at this moment.
- So, I think with that,
unless someone wants
to make an airplane out of a card
and send it up here pretty fast,
we've gotten through all the
questions that came from cards,
which puts Nick Spitzer on
for an in-depth summary
of the meeting. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Well, we are approaching
the end of our day,
and a very exciting day it's been.
You put it very well earlier, Mark,
characterizing this as a
very illuminating experience,
and I think that's an understatement.
Illuminating across scales of
time, across scales of space,
and Alipasha, I liked your
response to that last question
because I think that with new tools,
we see an ever more expanded scope,
the way in which neurons and other cells
that some claim have an important role,
are interacting in the brain.
And this then leads us, as it led you,
to suggest that there
may be reorganization
on different time scales and
spatial scales of activity
that we did not guess at
without actually being able to
see the larger scale of data.
So there are many people to thank here.
I want to thank, particularly,
Jennifer and Mark
for bringing us together here
and organizing the symposium.
I want to particularly
thank the featured speakers,
all of them, spectacular,
and really exciting data
that is fun to watch.
And I do want to take a quick moment
to thank again the KIBM staff,
I think they're probably
no longer with us,
but they have done a fantastic
job behind the scenes,
and in front of the scenes,
putting this together for us.
And finally, I want to thank
all of you in the audience
for attending, for your
interest, and for your questions.
It's been a great day, thanks very much.
(audience applauding)
And we hope that you'll
be back in the future
for a series of future KIBM symposia.
Thanks again.
(soft music)